-You know our next guest
from his iconic role
as Luke Skywalker
in the "Star Wars" films
and his award-winning
voiceover work as the Joker.
He stars in the second season
of "Knightfall,"
which airs Monday nights
on History.
Let's take a look.
-The worth of a man,
knight or Templar,
is proven in the theater of war.
-Luciferians count
battle-hardened warriors
amongst their number
with real weapons
at their disposal.
-God demands
we defend his principles,
training complete or not.
Line up for combat!
Any man who dies defending
God's will dies a noble death.
Never forget that.
-Please welcome to the show
Mark Hamill, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-What a joy it is
to have you here.
-It's nice being had.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's great.
And that is --
I feel like
that is a Mark Hamill
I have not seen before
in "Knightfall" here.
-You know what's so great is,
when you get into all that gear,
and you look in the mirror,
Mark Hamill's gone.
-Yeah.
-So, I don't feel like
I have to take any
responsibility for my actions.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause he's highly unlikable.
He's sort of a latter-day
drill sergeant.
And he's just brutal.
You know, and I have sort of a
rudimentary grasp of religion,
but he's saying to the troops,
"Once you complete this course,
you shall become a member
of God's executioners."
I thought, "Wait a minute.
That's my favorite Commandment."
-Yeah, right.
[ Laughter ]
-"Thou shalt not kill."
It's right up there with --
-Yeah. Way up top.
-Right up there with "Never
covet thy neighbor's wife."
[ Laughter ]
So he's a perplexing guy.
But like I say, it was unlike
anything I've done before.
And that's what you look for.
At least what I look for
is the challenge.
-Sure.
-Just not repeat yourself.
'Cause eventually "Star Wars"
is gonna go away.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But you never know.
You never know, yeah.
-And look,
it comes out in December,
so I only have eight months
of trolling left.
-Right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I love to tease
the fans online.
It drives them crazy.
I'm sure Disney's
not that happy about it.
But what are they gonna do,
fire me?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, right.
It's like the safest --
the safest job.
-It's too late.
Hey, Fred Armisen!
I'm a big fan.
Oh, my gosh.
-Thank you. Likewise.
-Oh, wow.
-It's a really big night
for Fred.
-"Portlandia."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is there anything he can't do?
-There really is nothing
Fred can't do.
-It's shocking -- author, actor,
comedian, drummer.
-Yeah, he's everything.
-Exactly.
-One thing that I think
now people know about you
is you are a preeminent
voiceover actor.
-Oh, yeah.
-And so, when you go
in front of camera
on something like "Knightfall"
or going back
to the "Star Wars" movies,
is it a lot of adjustment
to get in that kind of acting
versus your voice acting?
-Well, that's the problem.
When I read the script, I sort
of had my voiceover head on.
I didn't really
think it through.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-And I didn't realize
the undertaking
until I went to wardrobe.
And they just start
putting on layers and boots
and belts and capes
and shoulder pads.
And then just that makeup alone
is over an hour
in the makeup chair.
Because there's --
-There's some scars and stuff.
-Full wig, full mustache,
full beard...
-Yeah.
-...three or four facial scars.
And they do aging
on your hands and your face.
It's one of those things, too.
And I couldn't shave
my real beard,
'cause I was doing
something else.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, no.
Oh, no.
The cat's out of the bag.
-See? See?
They're just
desperate for spoilers.
[ Laughter ]
They're hoping I just have
a slip and accidentally...
-Yeah, yeah.
-...you know, reveal all.
-That one didn't seem
that accidental, yeah.
-No, no.